hey guys Pete here today I'm gonna do a
full recap of dark season 2 part of what
I love about this show is its complexity
but I tried to keep this video on the
shorter side that meant that I had to
leave out some of the smaller details
which I love so make sure to drop a
comment if you have questions about
something that I didn't get into in this
recap I plan on doing more dark videos
while we wait for season 3 so hit the
subscribe button if you're a fan of the
show obviously this is a recap of
everything that happened in dark season
2 and will be full of spoilers if you
haven't seen it yet
the first episode of dark second season
opens in a time period we haven't seen
yet there are two characters who at
first glance aren't anyone we've seen
before the time period is 1921 and the
characters who we see digging the
passage in the caves are a younger Noah
and who I presume to be an older bartosh
we never get confirmation that this is
Bart Oz on screen but I would be shocked
to learn that's not the case
Noah kills the second man with the
pickaxe after he accuses him of losing
his faith in their group SiC Mundus
before he struck down he tells Noah that
he hopes that a day will come where he
doesn't believe everything that Adam
tells him he says that he should ask him
why he took him in and why he chose to
call him Noah Adam whose face is covered
with scar tissue is the leader of
sickness and the older Noah who we met
in season 1 is also a member we learned
that they're looking for missing pages
from the triquetra notebook and Adam
says the apocalypse must come to pass
younger Jonas wakes up from a dream of
having sex with Marta in the future
remember he was sent there after
touching young Helga through the
wormhole that opened in the bunker in
the season 1 finale season 2 takes place
in June episode 1 is on the 21st so it's
just over six months removed from most
of the events from season 1 which
happened in November Jonas has been
stuck in 2053 for a while and he wants
to travel back to stop the apocalypse on
June 27th we see him collecting
materials and listening to tapes that
Claudia made at some time before he
arrived and older Elisabeth Doppler is
in an important role in the future she
guards the area around the nuclear plant
called the dead zone
and kills people who try to get inside
at this point we don't know why she's
doing that other than we hear them say
sick moondust create assess during a
hanging but we do learn that Jonas is
determined to enter the power plant and
when he does he finds a mysterious
floating blob inside in 2020 we meet a
new investigator named Claussen who we
later learn volunteered for the position
of starting a task force with Charlotte
six people have been missing for more
than six months in bendin and everyone
is on edge stranger yonus arrives at his
childhood home right in time to
interrupt Hannah who's holding Boris
knee Wald's gun to her throat he reveals
his identity to his mother and also
tells her about her husband Michaels
true identity as Mikkel Nielsen some
other set up things that happen in the
premiere Alexander Tiedemann announces
that the power plant will be closing
which means he has to hide the yellow
barrels he decides to bury them under
concrete inside the plant so that no one
will be able to find them
Bart Asha and Marta break up and later
we see him meet Noah and go inside the
caves in 1921 we see older Noah talking
to his younger self who's having a hard
time after killing the man at the caves
young Elizabeth finds a picture of sick
mundus in a book at HG tan houses shop
and identifies Noah to Peter
he tells Charlotte and we see that
they're working together putting
together Clues in the bunker in the
second episode old Claudia visits her
younger self to tell her about time
travel in vinden and later gives her a
map telling her where to find the time
machine she stresses that her younger
self needs to stop Adam and plants the
seeds that things could turn out
differently with Regina and her father
if she succeeds Egon Tiedemann is now
retired and it's been diagnosed with
cancer he begins thinking about things
and interviews Helga dopler who resides
in a mental facility he can't provide
any useful information about Matt's
disappearance the year before a gun then
decides to inquire about the man he
arrested 34 years ago for the murders of
Eric and Yasin and the disappearance of
young Helga Doppler it turns out Ulrich
is still alive and has been confined to
a psychiatric unit this whole time he
doesn't tell a gun anything useful but
the interaction makes him suspect that
he was
long about what happened back in 1953 in
2020 Claussen and Charlotte visit Regina
Tiedemann for an interview
Clausen seems to have an interest in
Regina's husband Alexander Regina
mentions that stranger Jana stayed in
her hotel during the disappearances and
she gives them a box filled with his
belongings that he left behind
Charlotte notices pages from her
grandfather's book and she makes an
excuse to leave elsewhere stranger yonus
brings Hanna back to 1987 to show her
Mikkel living with a Nez Hannah now
understands that her husband Michael was
a time traveler and the son of the man
she was having an affair with in 20:53
Jonas gets caught by Elizabeth trying to
re-enter the dead zone after gathering
fuel he needed to make things work he's
about to be hanged
but Elizabeth saves him at the last
minute choosing to imprison him instead
her translator cilia freeze Jonas
because she wants to know why Elizabeth
let him live and what she's hiding
Jonas and Celia go back to the black
blob inside the power plant which we
found out is known as the god particle
from one of Claudia's tapes the episode
ends as Jonas enters the stabilised god
particle
leaving cilia and 2053 behind in Episode
three young Helga becomes the first
successful traveler through a new and
improved chair Noah sends him back to
1954 where he returns home to everyone's
surprise young Aegon tries to learn what
happened from the boy but he won't speak
to anyone until older Noah comes to
visit him later
older claudia meets with agnes Nielsen
in the bunker in 1954 we learned that
Agnes and Noah are siblings and that
she's on the outs with sick mundos
Claudia gives her a newspaper clipping
which will see her take to Noah later in
an effort to rejoin sickliness we
learned that it's a story about
Claudia's death
Claudia goes to visit her father at the
police station and then visits HG tan
house for one last time she gets
confronted by Noah who tells her she's
going to die before he shoots her
Claudia makes a comment about him being
a pawn in a game he still doesn't know
how to play she says if you were free
you would have a choice and then he
kills her anyway when Noah recovers the
missing pages from the notebook he's
visibly
joke we hear him mention Charlotte's
name saying no this isn't right this
isn't true in 1987 a lot of stuff
happens
Ulric tells Aegon who he is and that
he's from the future when he goes back
to visit him later he brings a photo of
Mikkel with him and that sets
Ulric into a violent rage Aegon also
tells his daughter about his cancer
middle Claudia visits town house for the
first time with his book he explains the
bootstrap paradox when something exists
because it was sent back in time and
therefore has no point of creation he
tells her the book found me before I
even wrote it
she then travels for the first time to
2020 where she looks in on Regina and
sees that she's sick
in 1921 Adam asked Noah if he recovered
the pages from the triquetra notebook he
says that Claudia got what she deserved
in the end we all get what we deserve in
episode 4 we find out where yonas went
after he entered the god particle he's
in 1921 where he meets a young or Noah
who later takes him to meet Adam in his
lair under the church Adam reveals that
he is the oldest version of Jonas and I
for one believe that in 2020 adult
Claudia is at the library doing research
on what happened to her and her father
she learns that her father died and that
she disappeared she then goes back to
1987 in 2020 with three days to go until
the apocalypse things are starting to
take shape Marta Franziska Elizabeth and
Magnus start working together to figure
out what's going on and eventually they
run into Bartos in the caves they end up
taking the time machine from him not
knowing what it is and they leave him
there overnight Hannah and stranger
Jonas talk to Charlotte and after
sharing what they know decide to tell
Katarina about it at first she thinks
they're all crazy but later goes to the
school and finds Mikkel in the 1986
class photo Claussen also interviews
alexander learning that his last name
was Koehler before he married Regina but
we don't know why this is important yet
in the fifth episode Adam tells Eunice
that he can change the future and the
past if he prevents his father from
killing himself Adam shows yonas his god
particle time machine under the church
can operate outside the 33 year cycle
and take you to any day you want to
travel to
yonas travels to the day before michael
committed suicide in 1987 Ulrich breaks
out of the psychiatric ward and finds
Mikkel but they get caught by the police
before they can enter the caves
Claudia also learns about the yellow
barrels from burn Doppler who asked her
to keep things a secret at least until
he dies in 2020 Charlotte reveals to
stranger yonus that hd10 house is not
her real grandfather and that she never
knew her parents later Noah finds
Charlotte and reveals that he is her
father but won't reveal who her mother
is the teens make bartosh show them how
the time machine works and they take a
brief trip to the 1980s when they return
Marta finds the st. Christopher pendant
that stranger yonis left on her pillow
episode 6 is the odd episode in this
season that doesn't occur in the lead-up
to the apocalypse instead we are in 2019
the day before Michael kills himself
young yonus arrives from 1921 which
means we have two versions of the
younger yonas walking around at the lake
the original one finds the st.
Christopher pendant while he's sitting
with Marta they talk and almost kiss but
he leaves abruptly telling her that he
has to go teach his grandma how to use
her new tablet traveling young Jonas
then pulls a switcheroo because in his
mind he's going to talk his father out
of committing suicide which will mean
he'll never exist
he tells Marta you and I are perfect for
each other never believe anything else
they share a kiss which will lead to his
slightly younger self getting laid later
that evening the Nielsen's are throwing
a party to celebrate Katerina and
Ulrich's wedding anniversary young Jonas
and Hannah go to the party while the
traveling young Jonas talks to his
father
we learned that Michael hasn't been
suicidal and he reveals that it was
Jonas who led him into the caves and
took him to 1986 older Claudia arrives
and tells the Onis that Michael must
kill himself so everything happens the
same way it always has Jonas is
persuaded and after a tearful goodbye he
leaves Michael to write his suicide
letter in episode 7 older Claudia's dead
body
is discovered in the woods in 1954 Hagen
thinks that she may have played a part
in Helga's kidnapping
he asked the boy about her but he only
responds by calling Claudia the white
devil after stealing the time machine
from stranger yonas Hanna arrives in
this time period to visit Ulrich after
talking to him she decides to leave him
where he is
later in Agins office she says that
she's looking for a fresh start
indicating that she might stay in 1954
for a while
in 1987 it's the day of her father's
death and Claudia is trying to prevent
it he tells her that he knows about time
travel and she tries to play dumb at
first things escalate to where he
figures out that she knows and she gets
angry he tries to call the police to
tell them what he knows and they get
into a fight where she tries to take the
phone from him he falls busting his head
open on a table and she decides to let
him bleed out thinking that this has to
happen so that he will later be saved
before he dies he says you are the white
devil when she returns to her home
younger traveling Jonas arrives and
tells her that they have to leave he
says he knows what she did but says it
doesn't have to happen that way again
when she asked where they're going he
says the future
Clausen confronts Alexander at the power
plant revealing that he had a brother
named Alexander Koehler who went missing
in 1986 and that he is not him in the
season 2 finale
yonis explains to Claudia everything
that her older self knew about time
travel and the coming apocalypse Yana
suggests that they probably can't change
the big things using time travel but
perhaps they can change the details he
says we can change a grain of sand in
with that the whole world
Charlotte learns that Alexander buried
the radioactive waste and she's worried
that Klaus ins investigation will lead
him to it she heads over to the power
plant to try to stop him we learned that
after finding out that Charlotte was his
daughter
Noah decided that he had to kill Adam
and he sets out to do that Adam isn't
fazed by this saying it's not his
destiny to die yet Noah tries but is
unable to shoot him and in the process
it's revealed that Noah's wife is an
older Elizabeth
meaning Elizabeth is both
Charlotte's daughter and her mother as
Adam is telling him that does not can
only be undone by destroying it
completely Agnes in the older Magnus and
who we presume as the older Franziska
enter the room
Agnes takes the gun from Noah and she's
able to use it to kill him adult Yanis
finds Marta and forces her to go into
the bunker at gunpoint he says he can't
watch her die again and begs her to stay
there you might be thinking that this
doesn't make sense because his younger
self saw her die and for me this is one
of those things that make dark gray even
though he knows it probably won't work
he still feels compelled to try which is
what I imagine all of us would do in
that situation even knowing full well
that we were at the mercy of a
deterministic universe at the nuclear
plant Clausen gains access and pretty
much goes straight to where the yellow
barrels are buried young Jonas and
Claudia go through the caves and
activate the time machine opening the
portal back up he explains that he's
accepted that he needs to play a part in
the disaster that he wants to prevent
Peter takes Elizabeth to the bunker to
keep her safe and when they opened the
door Marta runs out to find yonas
Claudia finds Regina and also brings her
to the bunker young Jonas and Marta are
reunited at his home where Adam shows up
Adam travelled to 2020 through the god
particle and he's there to kill Martha
he shoots her and explains that in order
for him to exist
yonis had to see her die and feel that
pain in 2053 we see Elizabeth go inside
the dead zone and activate the god
particle at the same time that Claussen
is having one of his police force used a
jackhammer to break into the concrete
that was poured over the yellow barrels
Charlotte gets there and tries to stop
him but he won't listen to her he
insists on opening it at that same time
elizabeth activates the god particle in
2053 older Magnus and his partner
activate theirs in 1921 and we watch as
the contents inside the yellow barrel
that Claussen opened becomes the god
particle we watch as a portal opens
we're Elizabeth in 2053 can see
Charlotte in 2020 they go to touch each
other and that's when the apocalypse
hits vinden we know that several of the
characters died because we saw their
graves in 2053 when Jonas was there he's
still in his home at Martha's side and
before the explosion can reach it he's
saved by a version of Marta who tells
him that she's from a different world
and that is where the season ends so the
original Marta dies and we learn that
there is one from a different world
however you want to describe it who
swoops in and she takes Jonas somewhere
we have to imagine it's wherever she
came from
Claudia Regina Charlotte and Peter and
also young Noah who showed up there
survived in the bunker stranger Jonas
found
Franziska Magnus and bartosh and took
them somewhere before the explosion hit
it certainly makes sense that they'll
end up in the 1921 timeline but we don't
know how many stops or what's going to
happen between now and then we don't
know what happened to the older
Elizabeth in Charlotte when they touched
where they ended up so it's pretty
exciting heading into season 3 let me
know if you have any questions in the
comments because I'm gonna leave it
there please like this video if you
enjoyed it and subscribe to my channel
if you haven't already and you're a fan
of dark I have more dark videos coming
up and thanks for watching I'll talk to
you soon